what's up camera Mark
wait you hear something
in Haunted Mansion I wanted everything
to feel as if it came right off of the
ride when I walked through the set oh my
goodness it's powerful to see it the
level of detail from the bus down to the
wallpaper you just felt like this really
feels haunted it's kind of amazing
seeing the Haunted Mansion come to life
what we wanted to do is preserve the
details that fans remembered and expand
the universe around them
what is this place it's a seance room
maybe I'll just do a little blessing get
us started God give us a break amen the
thing that makes the ride so cool is
that the Mansion already as a history
this place is legendary and our
characters are discovering it if we
don't solve this mystery we're stuck
here for eternity
ah Summit
for me the secrets of this movie was
always going to be the Ensemble it was
one of those great casts everybody loves
each other we bonded it was fun to go to
work every day it was so much fun we
laughed a lot
it's a unique story with moments of
levity and fun and there's a lot of
scares as well
when audiences come out of the theater
no
I want them to be like whoa wait a
minute hold up I'm scared but I want to
do it again
careful death lurks around every corner
[Music]